Today we call that following your dream, listening to your voice,...
...to your inner voice.
I encourage you to silence, not to silence that inner voice.
At the same time, I must warn you that following your dream comes with a price.
In my case, since I knew I would draw pictures,...
...I didn't feel the need to learn math, chemistry, Latin, etc, etc.
That turned out to be a big drawback...
...and I regret that.
Also, following that dream, listening to that little voice,...
...does not guarantee success.
I must really emphasize that.
Luck is an ingredient not to be overlooked.
I was lucky, a lucky late bloomer.
One day, Bill Martin Jr. asked me to illustrate his "Brown Bear, Brown Bear,..."
"...What Do You See?" after he had seen one of my illustrations for an advertisement.
A couple of years later, I wrote my first own book,...
...and I was very careful not to use words,...
...and it is called "1, 2, 3 to the Zoo."
At that time, I was 39 years old.
Soon afterwards, I absentmindedly punched holes with a hole puncher...
...into a stack of papers.
The holes made me think of a bookworm,...
...and with the help of my good editor, the bookworm became a caterpillar.
It was published when I was 40 years old.
You see, a good editor, a hole puncher in good working order,...
...and a little bit of luck take you a long way.